The SCP Foundation deals with plenty of different
Groups of Interest - cults, rival agencies,
criminal organizations, all of which have
some connection to anomalous artifacts and
creatures.
But there are some groups of interest who
are actually responsible for the creation
of anomalies, and few are as weird and intriguing
as the Doctor Wondertainment toy company.
Whether or not Doctor Wondertainment is a
real person or not is the subject of much
speculation, but whoever they are, the company
that bears their name has produced a multitude
of dangerous anomalous items that are currently
in Foundation containment.
Usually these anomalies take the form of highly
dangerous toys, but the company has also released
a very peculiar set of limited edition creations
- a set of 21 living, breathing, more-or-less
human beings known collectively as… the
Little Misters.
All of them are marked by tattoos of their
name and each comes with a card reading - “Wow!
You've just found yourself your very own Little
Mister, a limited edition collection from
Dr. Wondertainment!
Find them all and become Mr. Collector!!”
Let’s take a look and see what’s out there,
before you try and catch ‘em all.
SCP-905 – or Mr. Chameleon - is a living
being made up entirely of photons.
His form is described as “fuzzy, but definite”,
and he appears to be the rough shape of a
human male standing at approximately 175 centimeters
in height.
He has no mass due to being made solely of
light particles, at least not one we can measure,
and while he can move and speak, he cannot
manipulate objects in the world around him.
Mr. Chameleon, as his name suggests, can alter
the wavelength of the light coming from his
body in order to match the color of his environment.
He also has the ability to walk through any
transparent material.
SCP-2287 – or Mr. Headless – is a human
male who is mostly normal aside from his lack
of a head.
Mr. Headless is blind, but can somehow still
speak and hear, and does not need to eat.
Spending time around Mr. Headless can cause
people to experience dissociative episodes
where they begin to see themselves as headless
as well.
In an interview, Mr. Headless claims to have
been created for use as a Halloween decoration,
with his dissociative effect on others being
intended as a kind of spooky prank, even if
it does sound more like a form of torture.
Mr. Headless was found by the Foundation wandering
the streets of a Wisconsin town after he left
an attic where he had been kept with other
holiday decorations.
SCP-1799 – or Mr. Laugh – is a human male
standing 120 cm tall, who has the physical
characteristics of a classic circus clown
complete with grey and white skin, a red nose,
and comically long feet.
He is capable of communication, but everything
he says will be interpreted by those around
him as a joke.
No matter what he says, people around him
will start to laugh.
And the more he talks, the more people laugh.
In some cases, they can even laugh themselves
to death - for example, one D-class personnel
used to test the effects of Mr. Laugh started
laughing so hard that he lost his balance
and suffered a fatal cranial injury.
SCP-909 – or Mr. Forgetful – is a man
with apparent retrograde amnesia.
He appears aware of his condition and cannot
seem to recall any of his own memories.
The only way that information appears able
to enter Mr. Forgetful's long term memory
is if he writes it down.
However, whenever he does so, something strange
happens - the memory he's just written down
is instantly forgotten by anyone else who
was involved in the events.
SCP-3537 - or Mr. Shapey – is an amorphous
humanoid that changes shape, though this transformation
happens involuntarily.
All of Mr. Shapey's transformations are into
non-anomalous human beings, and they have
been seen taking their own notes on possible
anomalous properties each new persona could
have.
They describe these transformations as painful,
with the level of pain varying dependent on
how dramatic the change is.
Despite the pain, Mr. Shapey says they're
happy the way they are.
In an interview, they claimed to be the first
of the Little Misters, and their random transformations
were used as inspiration for the appearances
of all of the subsequent Little Mister designs.
SCP-1908 – or Mr. Soap – is a man who
constantly produces soapy water, which will
quickly fill up any area he's in and cause
all surrounding surfaces to become slippery.
The soap can be easily cleaned up with normal
methods, but the levels of the liquid being
produced by Mr. Soap's body have to be constantly
monitored.
When the Foundation discovered him, he was
in a factory in China where he had been put
to work cleaning the machinery.
SCP-913 – or Mr. Hungry – is a middle-aged,
African American male wearing a dress shirt
and pants, who is capable of eating almost
any material.
Mr. Hungry is given nutrients intravenously,
and must be provided with a full day's worth
of calories every two hours, or else he will
enter a hunger trance.
While in this trance state, he is capable
of biting with a force of up to 5,000 newtons
and will devour anything and everything around
him.
His metabolism is so fast that drugs and toxins
have no effect on him, including amnestics
and anesthesia.
SCP-629 – or Mr. Brass – is a massive
brass automaton, standing at 170 cm and weighing
500 kilograms.
All parts of Mr. Brass' body are removable
and can be rearranged with only mild discomfort
to Mr. Brass himself.
Projections show that there are at least 73
billion possible combinations of Mr. Brass'
body parts.
When Mr. Brass was discovered by the Foundation,
he had been taken in by the Church of the
Broken God, who believed him to be a religious
idol and worshipped him as a deity.
SCP-644 – or Mr. Hot – is a man who can
both accurately guess the number of children
that any person has, biological or otherwise,
and predict the material wishes of any child.
He also claims to be able to accurately predict
the popularity of any product aimed at children.
When approached, he will offer a business
card that identifies him as Dr. Wondertainment's
marketing consultant.
He was found sleeping in the hallway of a
school in Racine, Wisconsin, a town that was
later found to contain many children with
anomalous Wondertainment toys in their possession.
In interviews, Mr. Hot describes his job as
being able to identify which children would
get the most use out of a Wondertainment toy.
In his own words - “You can't just give
this kind of craftsmanship to just anybody.
You give the average kid a realistic racecar,
he's just gonna leave it on the shelf and
go stare at the sun or something.”
SCP-2396 – or Ms. Sweetie – is a female
humanoid who stands at 250 cm tall and weighs
101 kg.
She lives entirely on sugar and foods containing
sugar, and claims to be in pain when denied
her sweet ”fuel.”
She has a repellent effect on males, a feature
which she says is meant to “keep nasty brothers
and their friends out”.
Anomalous hard candies will appear at random,
anywhere in a 6 km radius of Ms. Sweetie's
location.
When ingested by females, the candies are
perfectly harmless, but any masculine-presenting
humans who eat them start to undergo transformation
into a being made entirely of living candy.
These candy entities are resistant to blunt
force trauma, but can be easily dispatched
with fire and will obey any command given
to them by any person who identifies as female.
SCP-1007 – or Mr. Life – is a male humanoid
who goes through the entire human life cycle
every 75 minutes, ageing at a rate of one
year per minute.
Mr. Life has a keyhole in his back that when
a key is inserted into it, can reverse the
ageing process.
Each turn of the key regresses Mr. Life one
year younger until he's fully regressed to
a newborn baby.
Mr. Life was seized from a California mansion
after he had been purchased at an auction
held by Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd., another
Group of Interest that provides the wealthiest
and most powerful people in the world with
objects and experiences that would otherwise
be impossible without the help of the anomalies
they trade in.
Other Little Misters were also sold at the
auction, though the buyer of Mr. Life couldn't
recall who they were or exactly which Little
Misters they had bought.
The tattoo on Mr. Life's back reads “Mr.
Life and Mr. Death”, which may imply that
Mr. Life has a counterpart that the foundation
has not yet been able to identify.
SCP-527 – or Mr. Fish – is a non-anomalous
man with no physical abnormalities of any
kind, save for the fact that he has the head
of a fish.
He was discovered in Boston in 2002 and moved
to Site 19 in 2004.
In his initial interview with Fondation researcher
Dr. Baker, Mr. Fish was very frank and up-front
about his lack of interesting qualities - “Like
I told the other guy, this is all it is.
You're looking at it.
Lie, Stripes, Hot, Sweetie, they got all the
good stuff.
I'm just the guy with a fish head.”
SCP-917 – or Mr. Moon – is an elderly
man whose facial features wax and wane in
time with the lunar cycle.
On nights when the moon is full, his face
is normal, and his face is completely blank
on nights of a new moon.
This is painless for Mr. Moon, but he does
lose his sense of sight, hearing, and smell
when his face is in its new moon state, and
he claims that the experience leaves him very
tired.
SCP-2855 – or Mr. Money – is a Latin American
man who is anomalously affected by any business
transactions regarding his ownership.
As soon as any person exchanges money for
ownership of Mr. Money, and creates any kind
of written proof of that ownership, Mr. Money
will be teleported to their location.
Mr. Money's abilities are also subject to
the beliefs of whoever claims ownership of
him, and will display any anomalous properties
that are written as part of his contract.
Mr. Money was recovered in 2007, taken from
the holdings of Marshall, Carter and Dark,
LLP, a branch of the same company that had
previously sold Mr. Life.
When Mr. Money was discovered, MC&D had been
selling and buying him back repeatedly in
order to test his adaptive capabilities.
SCP-920 – or Mr. Lost – is an Asian man
in a green hoodie who seems to do nothing
but wander aimlessly.
Transportation and containment of Mr. Lost
are impossible, as any attempts to do so can
result in a variety of natural disasters and
other destructive phenomena.
He has a kind of psychic pull on those around
him, who feel compelled to walk and talk with
him.
Mr. Lost doesn't seem to suffer from any environmental
effects, as he has been spotted wandering
deserts and tundra with no apparent harm coming
to him whatsoever.
SCP-2284 – or Mr. Lie – is a man of Indian
descent whose voice has a cognitohazardous
effect on anyone who hears it.
Any statement that Mr. Lie says will be perceived
as true, despite the fact that Mr. Lie is
physically incapable of telling the truth.
Because of this, Mr. Lie communicates mainly
via rhetorical questions, which is the only
way he can express what he means.
SCP-2428-1 – or Mr. Mad – is a man in
a multicolored straightjacket who can only
be seen by those possessing the document designated
SCP-2428, a document which serves as proof
of purchase.
Mr. Mad is essentially an imaginary friend,
who can only be seen by the lone person in
possession of the SCP-2428 document.
In interviews, Mr. Mad expresses a belief
that he was a real person once, before being
rendered imaginary by Dr. Wondertainment.
In fact, there is evidence to suggest many
of the Little Misters were once ordinary people.
SCP-2933 is a partially submerged steel structure
located in a saltwater reservoir, a structure
which contains SCP-2933-A – or Mr. Scary.
The interior of SCP-2933 is constantly changing,
and seems to move and shift in a way that
directs anyone who enters towards Mr. Scary.
Once inside the structure, there is no way
back to the entrance.
Despite his name, and despite the sense of
dread surrounding the steel structure, Mr.
Scary doesn't seem interested in scaring people.
He self-identifies as Mr. Smiles, and seems
to have the personality of a young child.
His body is, like his containment, covered
in rust, a condition which he claims was transferred
to him by his father and which he says is
very painful.
While he does have a tattoo naming him Mr.
Smiles, a rusted patch of his skin appears
to have been marked with “Mr. Scary, property
of The Factory”, suggesting that they may
have had something to do with his rusted condition.
SCP-2148 – or Mr. Stripes – is a man wearing
a white blindfold.
If the blindfold is removed, anything that
Mr. Stripes tries to commit to memory - whether
that's a passage of text, a scene from a movie,
or a person's face - becomes censored by large
black bars in all existing records.
Mr. Stripes refers to Mr. Lie as his brother,
and believes himself to be the first Little
Mister, although he was told that by Mr. Lie,
so take it with a grain of salt.
Based on Mr. Stripes' testimony, Mr. Lie spent
a lot of time with him, traveling around and
making use of their combined abilities to
break into secure government buildings.
Even though they were close, Mr. Stripes has
never directly looked at Mr. Lie.
As he tells it, Dr. Wondertainment told him
that he wasn't supposed to look at Mr. Lie
yet.
And then last but not least, is Mr. Redd,
who has not been given a designation, and
is listed as a ”discontinued” Little Mister.
His story is a topic that would take an entire
video to explain altogether, but he may just
be the most violent, powerful, and dangerous
of all the Little Misters.
As interesting as the Little Misters are,
they're not the only anomalous creations of
the mysterious Dr. Wondertainment.
So, let us know in the comments if you'd like
to hear more about this twisted toymaker.
After all, nothing makes you feel more like
a child at heart than running in terror from
a Dr. Wondertainment original.
Now check out “SCP-3082 - Neverland’s
Lost Boys and Girls” and “SCP-3008 - Trapped
In Ikea” for more strangeness from the world
of the SCP Foundation!